none of these kids should be getting the
media attention that we're getting like
on we we aren't experts we don't have
all the solutions with you we don't have
that much time because our next guest is
a diva
well he's no David hog I'll tell you
that much I can follow him on the
Twitter at Kyle cash of of course a
student at Stoneman Douglas high a lot
of people don't remember the high school
that's how quickly news please parkland
Florida and we had him on the show and
ever since then he's now been
gallivanting around with all the other
important hosts and politicians Kyle how
are you sir yanari well I would have
been doing better if you'd have had a
pair of headphones anywhere in your
house I feel like I thought that was a
Power Move I don't do headphones I don't
kalakashi doesn't do headphones Kyle
Kashyap doesn't do headphones maybe
that's for that that's for those other
kids at the town halls how have you been
doing so you remember you know you you
did our show we talked about this quite
we talked about everything that had been
going on it was still really hot in the
news and ever since then I've been
seeing you you everywhere well yeah we
were ever in DC and I uh I got I got the
flu from Oh meeting all the politicians
yes yes it's called it's called the
swamp flu that's true
yeah it's a particular strain and it
makes you a little bastard yeah for some
reason you have you don't have it you're
fine you the healthy relationship with
your wife you get it all of a sudden
you're hitting on men installs and truck
stops it's a very weird flu but who have
you been so first off let me tell you
I've said this before I'm very
uncomfortable generally speaking with
the idea of having anyone young kinda
underage on the show because I hate how
they were politicized in the media but I
do think there's a difference here
because first off you were kind of
dragged into it a little unwillingly you
know you wanted and what you were doing
is the other students were out there
immediately on every single outlet that
you we could pop you could possibly
imagine and all you said was like hold
on a second they don't speak for all of
us and so I think ok since they're
expressing an opinion for everyone it's
necessary to have a voice of reason like
yourself so do you feel like that's how
most people see you do you feel you've
been embraced at least as a voice of
balance or how have you been I think
it's that's pretty much where I came
into like the entire debate as in like
let's kumbaya this don't send out let's
find a middle ground
and so now is basically when I came in
because a it was representing the
conservative point of view in the Second
Amendment but but also finding the
middle ground we did find the middle
ground and while everyone was protesting
and marching we talked to legislators
and we got the stops groans Act passed
known to the house that's gonna hit the
Senate get on the Omnibus and pass the
day before the March well there you go
cuz you so you met with some US senators
right
I don't yeah I remember that I remember
how many money the caviar you can't
imagine the money
this would have follow us were they so
you member what is this what your
timeout now you found a middle ground
what is what is the middle ground
legislatively what what are we looking
at and I know you've played in a claim I
mean it's her we're not gonna pass
anything they have with gun control okay
the fact in like the Congress so
practically was everything that can be
done preemptively
to stop shooter without like talking
about gun control okay because I don't
even think gun control is the issue in
this debate it's clear like looking
factually gun control won't solve
anything so what we push we push the
stop school Act which lets teachers it
gives the funding for better recognition
of kids who do have these issues that
our treatment of these kids um better
development of technology at schools
itself and better communication between
the FBI in the schools right exactly and
that's important by the way that doesn't
even that doesn't necessarily get into
the territory what you're talking about
of hey you
you took a xanax so now you can't buy a
gun because of mental health issues
because that's why when we spoke oh
saying it was this idea was also way too
broad and we had we had done in a little
bit on something specific and and this
seems like this seems like a good start
and you're saying this is going to pass
the day before the March you believe
that if everything goes according to
plan they already passed the house
practically unanimous so what what will
this do for let's say let's walk us
through a scenario and I first often I
just find this thing I don't know I'm so
tickled that that that David hog is
everywhere he's like the NRA practically
threatened us but because I said they
don't like you he's out there on every
single show and at the same time
kyle is here any action legislation that
might make it the day before the March
the day before the pine final PR stand
they might already be up crap Creek so
let's go through a specific example
let's say a kid is really disturbed
exhibiting signs
what would this legislation allow for
for example we're help with that
wouldn't that we don't have right now in
place I mean right now right now
practically a little installation that
does is that it allows it teaches
teachers and our officers and students
how to properly identify these kids
okay hen reports into the proper
authorities because that right now a
teacher can't really do anything as of
right now and in teaching and like
educating these teachers on what to do
when they do meet a kid who has these
issues is a good step in the right
direction because honestly what happened
at my school could have been averted
like it could have been major that
wouldn't have happened had like people
followed the legislation in place
already right that well and and now this
is to strengthen that so how do you
identify someone I guess how do you how
do you ensure that it isn't and I know
listen I'm expect to have all the
answers because I know it listen your
your your younger chap well know what it
does is it doesn't here's a difference
it gives the funding to the states and
then the state's it's up to the states
to create the systems and to create the
programs to teach the teachers okay so
like the federal government what I've
been like very supportive I don't want
to see the federal government telling
the states what to do mm-hmm I think
it's up to the stage yeah so it gives
some money to the states and then the
state's decide what they want to do with
it they decide in what different aspects
of the bill the money needs to go to
right I can already see the backlash
from that this is gonna be a problem in
states are gonna just take that money
and they're gonna give it to the rich
oil buddies that's that's what they're
gonna say and then you're gonna be on
the hook for Halliburton Kyle do you
want to be on the hook for Halliburton
I forgot the bush the Bush years are for
in him imagine that growing up in
America where you really didn't go crazy
do you remember George W Bush as
president or is that where you just were
you too young to remember that
no okay I uh yeah see I grew up and that
was my high school years where you
probably grew up in a high school years
were everything Barack Obama did was
amazing I grew up in the high school
years were everything george w bush did
just everyone was I wouldn't
oh you know anything and then barack
obama happened and i was out of high
school and i no longer wanted to swallow
a knife every day so i one thing that it
does that I get concerned about as we
talk about like identifying students
listen high school for a lot of people
can be a really really depressing place
so yeah run into it so how do you know
you how do you differentiate or how do
we expect them to be handling reporting
different you know a kid who just says
like oh man I hate my life
I'd rather die than take the math test
versus some kid who's like this is that
these are the school plans and we're
make sure I wear this vest you know how
do we make sure that the it's
differentiated and not used as a tool
right where you just go hey that kid is
could shoot up to school and then he
gets on a crap list the kid is not
because it's really like it's a specific
specific matter it's the same thing of
like having the legislative and saying
that if you're mentally like disturb you
should be able to acquire weapon it's
the same debate of like being able to
properly identify the person they're not
overreacting I don't know so this is
more so about correcting the breakdown
in communication that happens between
like a state level you know they don't
really have it's about what every state
deems necessary what games like what
they want to do to ensure this won't
happen again
yeah and like in like a very like subset
group of what they're allowed to do and
it's very proud the group they can like
choose to go and like technology they
can choose to them it's a better the
communication between the FBI they can
work on like apps of reporting it's all
up to the states right yeah
well listen we've seen it when when I'm
in states with education tend to do
better than a one big federal
bureaucracy in Washington DC you know
what I loved is I just asked you the
question he said I don't know you know
who would never say don't know David
Hogg yeah have you ever heard David Hogg
say I don't know I don't think anyone
has really followed up on any questions
that's actually okay that's good that's
what we call a segue Colin you didn't
even realize cuz I was gonna be my next
question do you see any specific plans
other than NRA sucks and ban all
semi-automatic weapons like we saw at
CNN Town Hall do you see any concrete
legislative plans from your peers people
like David hog people who are in this
now now this is exactly happened in
school I talked to kids okay like what
you're right okay tell me anything you
want what do you propose and none of
them gave me anything nothing I talked
to it like so many periods today I'm
like like what do you propose like what
do you want to do like even if I don't
agree with you just what do you want to
see happen and none of them gave me an
answer and like it's practically the
same thing with the March to different
things with the March um there are
people in the March that saying that we
don't take away your guns I remember
David Hawk saying we don't wanna take
away your guns but specifically on the
website if you if you can you can pull
it up right now and scroll down it says
that you know one should be able to have
an assault rifle so there is a gun Genda
going on here and it is quite of
somewhat of an anti gun marks right it's
like no once again and I don't film the
actual legislative changes other than
that that are they're actually being
pushed all I hear is marching marching
is fine a few interactive ISM and we
raising awareness but you actually want
legislative change I talked with
legislators and you proposed something
nothing's being proposed right that's a
really very interesting point
first off when you say you spoke with
people today I know it wasn't David hug
cuz I saw him on the telly so I know
that he's not there he's too but he's
he's basically tutored onset Leonardo
DiCaprio and What's Eating Gilbert Grape
he's just on set and he's like alright
I'll I'll just get my GED got bigger
things to do
no that's a good point because and I
said we don't to take away your guns
just assault rifles well just assault
weapons well what's an assault weapon
and then you look into legislation and
it's basically all weapons other than
revolvers and pump-action shotguns it's
every hand it's every stubble stack
Glock it's every Walther our sponsor
there that you would use for personal
defense outside of the peace it's it's
the majority or certainly plurality now
I would actually absolutely say majority
majority of guns that people would use
for self-defense
so there you go that's exactly the point
they just so what defines an assault
rifle like you tell me what defines an
assault rifle it doesn't mean anything
well they said I think they just say
assault weapons anyone's all right
because I saw a weapon of war yeah yes
and by the way I know about the war
because I've been tat I've been tattered
by the war of dead Johnny Mathis a Don
Lemon on Ceres you guys mean tweets mean
tweets the NRA threatened to kill me no
way ha I got a pretty pretty sure no one
threatened to kill you they just said
that you were wrong sorry I know you
have to go back to school with him but
you know it's it's it's it's
uncomfortable and this is what I say
there's a very different approach
you get asked the question you say well
I don't know David Hogg knows everything
only there's no actual legislation there
are no propositions there whereas you've
met with legislators it is a
quintessential example I mean I'd
further on that and further I'm saying
that especially in the Town Hall that no
one further up on the questions when key
people said like stuff then we're like
outrageous no one followed through
saying like no that's not true or on
there like they say false false of on
live television no one falls through her
like questions then yeah at all yeah
well it doesn't good that's a good point
because they try to say that that I
member Dana lash didn't do that where
she what's the name of the girl looks
like the the Minority Report Oracle
shaved head you know who I'm talking
about she what's your schema Emma yeah
he probably the crushing on one point so
the point is she was up there and she
she goes don't say no on air because her
friends are gonna come after you the
chain gang and and so she goes dana lash
what of the inner I think she said low
so she you know she didn't do a research
on the name should what are you going to
do are you willing to stand up right now
and say that no one should own
semi-automatic it was something broad
enough where she basically included the
word semi-automatic weapons we can
probably people can go watch the clip
ain't it not fully set me ah yeah and I
fully semi-automatic and Dana lash
answers that listen what happened here
was a travesty this should not have
happened
this person definitely should not have
had a firearm so she was trying to find
middle ground and the girl goes you're
not answering my questions will you make
sure that no one has access to a
semi-automatic and everyone started
cheering him on a second she just
actually answered your question about
the Knicks background check what went
wrong here
all the red flags but you're saying
she's not answering your question unless
she commits right they're taking an oath
you know on the CNN spec sheet to ban
all semi-automatic weapons and she
doesn't know what semi-automatic is the
leading questions there and they cheer
but like you said no one ever questioned
them on it and that's a police officer
the sheriff the sheriff the sheriff it
would have been his job to say well hold
on sorry sorry sweetheart what what you
mean to say is you mean these
high-capacity specific rifles cuz cuz
the gun I have on my hip here's or not
that's a semi-automatic so you don't
mean to include that but no one followed
up yeah do you follow up and when you're
at school - please tell me you do I
think what do you mean like in school
all the things that we can't say that
we can't follow up do you do it for us
like you walk in honk oh I don't I
haven't talked to like any really one of
them like in school when I do as I like
to base with my friends like not my
friends but kids in class it might it
might don't turn it to the base with my
friends they're just straight-up
arguments in yelling because well I like
kids in my class before all this
happened I spoke with okay two kids from
like two leaders from the never again
movement and they told me that they want
to ban a fully automatic assault rifles
it advances 93 for sorry and then they
come on three like we want to bend all
all assault rifles and they couldn't
define them assault rifle is or like
which specific one so like it's an
indication that they truly don't know
right what they're talking about and
then it's specifically at school you
know um I would talk to kids and I would
say look you what do you want to do
they're like we have to been assault
rifles and I hit them with the statistic
and then they're like I don't like how
you tweet Kyle okay you're a damn what
yeah it's how you tweet it okay
how should I you do is that tell them
here's what you do repeat the fact and
say okay you know five hundred thousand
to three million defensive uses of
firearms each year the vast majority of
public shootings not committed by rifles
or quote unquote assault weapons assault
rebels of any kind how should I tweet it
ask them that no I can't tweet I'm
saying for you you I'm living
vicariously no I'm saying just tell ask
them say how should I tweet it and okay
that's that's actually very cute yeah
they would probably get to say they
probably would be like don't tweet it
exactly so that's that that once comes
down to they just don't want to hear
different points of view period I mean
it was the biggest factual evidence that
I just constantly say is that three
percent of all gun crimes with an
assault rifle sixty percent of those are
suicides and the majority is gang
violence and criminal activity right
well you don't the way even isn't even
an issue then you just say the same
thing the 1994 to 2004 clock like was
been proved inconclusive for actually
having an assault weapons ban I hate to
correct but because that's important
because assault rifle in the military
men
capable of burst fire assault weapons
doesn't mean anything and that includes
handguns with you know scary triggers so
they say assault rifles but the
legislation is assault weapons which
would ban handguns as well and that's
the point they don't even care that
because at the end game if you look at
the legislation
it's just they want to ban handgun oh
this is the 1994 2004 it was it was salt
weapons weapon was yeah yeah yeah it was
it was really really silly and it
included all kinds of magazine it
affected handguns and everything as well
let me ask you this since you've been on
our show what other programs I know I've
seen you in a few but what are the
programs have reached out to you
proactively to you know to get you to
appear I mean practically everyone
practically everyone um not like not in
like big big numbers like for like big
big league media big league media but uh
thank you no not you cancel on that free
mug we had sent out to mr. Keshav lock
of my hair I love you guys but uh no no
we have to make sure that I picked the
right interviews because I don't get
like my interview get it chopped up
right some left my interview and it
looks like I don't know what I'm saying
or okay well that's because you said
pick the right interviews so but are you
willing to do interviews with people who
disagree with you so long as yeah
definitely I did Piers Morgan piers
Morgan was fun okay tell us for those
who don't know tell us how that one I
mean it was 2:40 in the morning I hadn't
slept I had like half a was a dr. pepper
and we just got on air and then he just
started like spouting all this like
false false information that was just
like handling absolutely no substance to
the debate it was just like all random
facts about how an 8 year old girl shot
her father because they gave her an Uzi
machine gun range and she shot her
father and I'm like what does this have
to do with the actual debate and then
there was like other random facts that
he kept on like shoving in there that
had made like no sense yeah yeah so I
just like telling him like general facts
that like just facts that are well-known
well you know it's funny again I to joy
this contest because David hog is the
dark darling of the left right now okay
he doesn't do any voices of opposition
as far as the program's right he does
not I don't okay well like I mean that
makes sense because they would actually
like asked back follow-up questions
right but I'm trying to comparing it
with you worse on the flip side you can
see footage you know
into the crisis sector than which is
totally obviously false David Pogue is
not a crisis sector but that they took
that from footage of him going hold on
let me retake that so he wants edited
interviews with people who agree with
him you are like I have to pick my
interviews carefully now it's not like a
paper champion picking people who aren't
real contenders in boxing he's saying I
have to pick it carefully because I want
to I'm gonna find people disagree with
but I want to make sure they don't edit
me out of context cheap shot it is a
total 180 from David Hogg and in this
kid hogs the spotlight
well I can mess up really quickly and
like screw everything up just by like
saying one wrong line on my television
that's true that's true but the I
appreciate your your your your gonads
and willing to stand in there with
people who disagree with you you know no
none of these other kids are doing it I
think comment in the comment section
people who are watching this can we all
agree that none of the other kids are
doing this none of the other kids are
going on at Piers Morgan at 2:30 and
making sure it's unedited you're the
only one whether people agree or
disagree with you you're the only
teenager from parkland Florida doing
that that's got to feel good right
I mean it's fun I mean I had to beta I
can't debate like my normal friends at
school
yeah well I've only had one actual real
band with Piers Morgan but I mean I'd
love to have more I mean if anyone asked
me would you like to go and CNN or do
this there or actually like have a live
interview then sure what about some kind
of a town hall with you and some of your
fellow classmates have been making the
rounds is there any possibility of that
of since you all go to the same school
sitting down saying no let's let's have
a discussion of our own differing ideas
even if it's well that was like two
things two things happen with that the
first one was like Harvard invited
absolutely everyone except me further
discussion and I was like look we're
having a discussion
oops let's not invite the one Republican
from Stoneman Douglas right let's do
that and the same thing was with Twitter
with Twitter originally hadn't hadn't
invited me to do like a live stream
which is like if you're having a live
story about Stoneman Douglas at least
invite one kid from the opposite
opposite point of view but I'm doing an
interview with Twitter later on this
week I think okay I stream live stream
okay so but you weren't a part of that
initial one that was planned no no so
yeah what's the discussion then if
you're not there there is notice
it's just oh yeah I agree yeah yeah yeah
grumble grumble grumble yeah I feel like
if had I been there would've been a
discussion it would have quickly become
a debate well you know I think you're
pretty you know you're agreeable I don't
think you're a contentious person I just
think you just you disagree with some of
their views and you're actually far more
moderate probably than a lot of people
like myself are on the issue so I
certainly seemed I mean if you look at
even the Senators you've met with you
have reached across the aisle you didn't
slam dunk yeah president and brag about
it yeah I mean we met with senators
because we had we had to be reaching we
had to reach across the aisle because
this this act was like completely
bipartisan we have like this shouldn't
be just be a Republican issue or a
Democrat issue well let me ask you this
cuz David hog bragged about how he got a
call from Donald Trump and he hung up on
him and they were on Bill Maher and his
friend I can't member his friend they
both talked about happy yes I hung up on
the president so let me flip that let's
say tomorrow you get a call from
Elizabeth Warren or debbie Wasserman
Schultz or Bernie Sanders saying like
hey I'd like to what would would you
hang up on them I mean we've been trying
to contact Bernie Sanders and he has not
responded we also we reached out to
Hillary Clinton's daughter Chelsea
Clinton and we set up a meeting with her
before all this I live two weeks ago
were like so then she like she spouts
out her book deal but but we do want to
meet with people across the aisle Bernie
Sanders still hasn't responded just
ding-dong - him he goes nuts his order
pizzas and he's like I think it's
another testament to - Kyle's reaching
across the aisles it's a tweet of his
that I was he said a while I disagree my
classmates proposed on policy and
politics they're good people who've been
trying to advocate for what they believe
I just disagree with most of what they
say of attacking them as people is wrong
dissecting their arguments is more
effective I think that's also a very
unique tweet for a kid his age at your
age I would've liked the fact that you
recognize that is already you're you're
very ahead of your time
I couldn't tell you because I haven't
been there in over a week I couldn't I
don't know what's it like out there can
someone let me know yeah now that is
that is a very different approach why do
you think that is is that yeah is that
your is that your your Padre or your
Madre you know my mom finally have to
leave in like 15 minutes all right okay
well we'll wrap this up because I don't
want to get you in trouble with your
bizarre and this is an international
incident and a kid has been all over and
it's like I mean like honestly I'm to be
frank with you
none of these kids should be getting the
media attention that we're getting like
on we aren't experts we don't have all
the solutions why are we like parading
kids on CNN and why we can a be seen for
for what reason well because we're
exploitative and we have no shame that's
true I was waterboarded for ratings no
hear the reason why like I said it's I
agree with you but unfortunately they
have already been distressed into the
spotlight and they've said I speak for
all of Stoneman Douglas and so you're
the only person saying listen I don't
hate these kids I don't wish them but I
don't agree with them and they don't
speak for all of us and so yet I don't
have the luxury if someone like you
exists of not hosting you well yeah I
mean I think you're absolutely right and
there are definitely a bunch of
Republicans and stomach Douglas who
aren't represented in the media and I
think saying like I don't say I'm from
Republicans or even for all the kids at
Stoneman Douglas no they're like there
are kids with like a variety of like
viewpoints and Stoneman Douglas yeah I
know
it's like it's a select group of people
who have been like they kind of say that
they represent everyone from some in
Douglas which isn't you exactly well
this is the left they see everyone as a
monolith right okay you're black okay
you're a woman okay you're gay okay
you're at the oiran parkland Florida
psycho huh I can I'm a person and I have
a different point of view just because
David hog goes walks to the same
homeroom class that I do doesn't mean
that he agrees with me in everything
wait just because I'm black doesn't mean
that I agree with everything that Whoopi
Goldberg says wait just because I'm gay
doesn't mean that I think Liza Minnelli
kicks ass okay we have different
opinions and that's okay it's the same
symptom it's it's the moment
we see this year this is why I very much
appreciate you hosting a couple reasons
let me list this first off you're very
civil you're able to have a dialogue and
you're able to dissect ideas as opposed
to just going after the person which is
very admirable in someone your age
you're also able to say you don't know
and then maybe you'll look into it more
you also understand that people are
individuals and don't claim to speak for
everybody these are very very these are
very different from how the left see
people taking you are the exact it's
you're the one taking personal
responsibility and getting active
approaching legislators actually trying
to create real change which may happen
before the March which I just find
hysterical you're the kind of guy who
people should want if they're good if
they're going to exploit having a high
school kid on they should say let me
yeah what you they should they should
say at least this kid is the kind of kid
who we know is mentally stable enough to
handle an interview as opposed to
someone who's just going me me me me me
me me limelight limelight limelight it's
it's the unwilling kind of hero
so I hope other people see the
difference between you and and the
leftist for me we're actually doing
something good like we're actually
pushing something versus just marching
in the streets marching is fine like you
can march all you want but that's not
going to change the legislators opinions
I think what we managed to accomplish
it's quite amazing well I hope that
listen I hope that you do and I mean
I've talked about baby steps you saw
what happened in Maryland today where
the officer shot the gunman you know
it's one of things each and that kills
the entire narrative not having gun
school and I love that because someone
with a gun stopped the bad guy with the
gun and that's what needs to happen at
her school and it's like look this man
actually did the job he was paid to do
versus waiting outside and being a
coward and guns at schools are actually
a good thing
yes well exactly well it to be fair they
were waiting in their Lamborghini over
there no fire if I had those if I had
those bucket seats I wouldn't leave them
for a while all right get out of you
know that's a good point here's the
thing it doesn't dig a well that's a
trained police officer well we had
trained officers in your situation who
didn't do what they're supposed to do we
have people who get their concealed
carry a far less likely to commit crimes
they're far more trained in firearms in
the average person and at least it gives
you a fighting shot I say I don't want
to mandate that all teachers carry
firearms but if a teacher can carry a
firearm at a
any's or anywhere else because he's gone
through the class he has the permit he
should be allowed to protect himself and
his students at school we see that today
even if it's an officer the only thing
that stops the bad guy with a gun yeah
good guy with a gun like the gun isn't
gonna magically disappear like no one's
gonna stop the shooter and someone has
to stop the shooter right and then
people I was gonna say this before you
said this but did you try I find it
funny how like people like Bernie
Sanders are calling for like gun reform
and then it's like look if you want to
take away guns and give up your arm
security right no you're exactly right
and by the way the gun that the gun the
police officer use guarantee you that
would be an assault weapon because the
magazine capacity would put it under
that category Tybee tried darting into
the the hallways and offering a buyback
program yes have you tried that next
time yeah just offer a buyback that's
how they do it that's tell them it's
mandatory that'll get them it's
mandatory exactly it's a mandatory
buyback I'm sure the the gunman's from
here forth from henceforth will abide
turn that a aren't is smart it's like
it's all so hypocritical they're like
give us trust the government even more
give us give away your guns trust the
government but the government failed us
in so many different levels it's like
trust the government more even after
they failed well people need to see I
don't know that we need to trust the
government and David Howard might not be
the hero we need but the one we deserve
I know you can get I would love to have
the kid in my show where's the best
place for people to find you and follow
this legislation that you've been
working on and mean with politicians
where's the best place uh Twitter how
you catch up with that that that bars me
from the equation I can't follow you so
I don't wanna get you in trouble with
your mom but Kyle I really appreciate
you coming on the program keep us
updated amen
keep up the good fight I know high
school can I'll hit you up on Twitter do
you like this video of course you did
let's there something wrong with you in
which case you can comment below what's
your problem with this video we want to
hear from you and we promise you 100% I
give you my word as my bond will answer
every single negative comment for those
who are normal you can leave a thumbs up
and subscribe